[Applause]
a call that rang out across russia this
saturday
in moscow they'd seen how cities across
this vast landmass had come out to
protest
and how the police had responded
from vladivostok in the russian far east
to temperatures of minus 50 in yakutsk
siberia
in city after city as the time zones
rolled past
thousands tens of thousands on the
streets and arrest after arrest
[Music]
even before the rally started in moscow
the police were already busy
picking protesters at random out of the
crowd
navalny's wife julia was detained before
she'd even joined the rally
his key ally lubov sobel arrested as she
spoke to the crowds
and arrested
it's a tether war basically between the
protesters trying to keep hold of their
friends
and the rivalries
[Applause]
[Music]
completely unnecessary against peaceful
protesters
and all the time the tannoy blaring for
people to keep their masks on
to socially distance but not much chance
of that
this golden lube rush a reference to the
600 pound version
in what navalny says is putin's palatial
residence on the black sea
that investigation putin's palace it's
called has had
70 million views on youtube since it was
released on tuesday
demonstrators building their own little
version out of snow
i don't like how we live in this country
this woman says here the elderly have to
look through rubbish bins
and some people have palaces like
navalny showed us
do you think you'll be able to secure
navalny's release by coming out into the
streets though
i don't think we're gonna secure his
release
per se just by coming out to the streets
but we
have to tell the government that we
don't agree with these policies that we
don't agree with this behavior and that
we don't think it's okay
we need them to know that the people
don't agree with this and that we're
gonna fight and that we're gonna express
our opinions
even if they beat us arrest us and find
us
ridiculous finds
as evening fell a committed group moved
on to the prison where he's being kept
the final violent arrests in a day of
nationwide protest
as navalny's team called for the same
again next week dinah magley sky news
moscow